drei tage haben palästinensische
terroristen raketen aus gaza in richtung
israel abgefeuert jetzt haben beide
seiten eine feuerpause zugestimmt diese
waffenruhe sozusagen die es in der nacht
um 22.30 unserer zeit in kraft getreten
ja nur wenige stunden zuvor waren am
sonntagabend sirenen in tel aviv zu
hören zivilisten nach hasteten in
schutzräume viele erzählten von dunklen
explosionen zu hören waren insgesamt
haben die palästinenser terroristen seit
freitag knapp 1000 raketen abgefeuert
bei einem luftschlag hatte israel zuvor
dem top terroristen teilte al jabari
ausgeschaltet und wir gehen ins land
beginn nach tel aviv zu unserer bild
reporterin antonia jamin antonia ich
grüße dich und wir wollen natürlich
heute nach dem regal gehört haben mehr
als 1000 raketen wissen wie stabil diese
ausgehandelte waffenruhe ist oder sein
könnte
guten morgen kai also ich muss so sagen
der waffenstillstand ist ja gestern 22
uhr 30 deutscher zeit eingetreten es hat
genau acht minuten gedauert bis der
islamische dschihad die nächste rakete
schon auf israel geschossen hat also so
stabil ist es aber tatsächlich war die
nacht relativ ruhig ich muss sagen ich
bin jetzt nicht wirklich ruhig ins bett
gegangen so ein waffenstillstand ist
niemals wirklich 100% man weiß wie wer
auf der andere seite ist und werden dann
wieder eine rakete ab schießt man kann
auch jetzt sehen ich stehe ja jetzt
gerade in tel aviv man kann auch den
strand sehen wir sind ja im august es
gibt sommerferien eigentlich dieser
strand ist in eine normale zeit
eigentlich komplett voll mit leute mit
familien mit kinder und mit touristen
und man kann jetzt sehen dass dieser
strand sehr sehr leer ist es sollte
jetzt vorbei sein aber in israel ist
niemals wirklich irgendwas vorbei und
ich sag mal so meiner einschätzung in
paar monate gibt es hier wieder noch mal
so ein kleiner krieg oder sogar ein
großer krieg
sagst es ist niemals ganz vorbei man
kennt dort in tel aviv diese ausnahme
situation dennoch in 55 stunden antonia
1000 raketen wirst du das erlebt wie hat
sich das alles für dich angeführt was
konntest du beobachten
also in israel leben und ganz normale
und plötzlich passiert das an alle
verstehen dass es dass es alarm ist ich
muss sagen ich war gestern selber in tel
aviv mit der waffenstillstand sollte
eigentlich 20 uhr eintreten fünf minuten
vor 20 uhr alarm mitten in tel aviv alle
leute müssen sofort zum schutzraum
rennen der wahn frauen da waren kinder
da war eine frau mit dem baby ich selber
wurde ich bin ja jetzt mutter das war
ich im letzten krieg noch nicht und
plötzlich sehe ich da diese mutter mit
ihrem baby dass die hat es so umarmt
quasi wenn irgendwas passiert dass es
das kind nicht trifft und es war schon
auch für mich person nicht was plötzlich
anders weil der krieg vor sechs jahren
zugetan der war 51 tagen ich war ich
werde sehr oft draußen ich habe das
alles gesehen aber ich hatte noch keine
kinder damals und plötzlich auch als
mutter es ist total anders das zu sehen
aber von der anderen seite kann man auch
sagen dass es sehr viele solidarität auf
den straßen von israel gibt in diesen
zeiten sofort wenn alarm es dann sieht
man wie leute ihre häuser auf machen und
leute von der straße rufen kommt kommt
rein kommt in uns einen schutzraum nur
damit alle ok sind dank gott ist iron
dome hier im einsatz und hat auch
wirklich 96% erfolg gehabt also die
raketen sind fast nicht eingetroffen und
das ist einfach ein wunder unsere bild
reporterin antonia jamin du bist jetzt
auch plötzlich im israelischen fernsehen
aufgetaucht es gibt ein artikel von bild
über den plötzlich das ganze land
spricht
genau ich muss sagen bild ist jetzt
gerade die beliebsten zeitung in israel
kein scherz und der grund einfach weil
bild die wahrheit gesagt hat gestern
erschien ein artikel bei bild indem man
einfach die wahrheit sagt indem man
erzählt hat darüber dass eine
palästinensische rakete vom dschihad von
dem islamischen dschihad sie wollten auf
israel schießen haben es aber nicht
geschafft und diese rakete ist leider
muss man auch so sagen in gaza
eingetroffen und hat da kinder
umgebracht die ist also die slum die der
jüdische islam wollte sofort propaganda
machen und hat versucht zu sagen das ist
eine israelische rakete war der ibf die
israelische armee hatten sofort die
bilder und haben gezeigt dass es nicht
eine israelische rakete war sondern eine
palästinensische rakete bild hat es auch
so groß gemacht war einer der einzigen
medien outlet quasi auf der welt dass es
so schnell aufgedeckt haben und und die
israelis waren erstaunt weil hier in
israel ist man wirklich daran gewohnt
das international die palästinensische
propaganda sehr sehr stark ist und davor
hat man hier gestern bild sehr sehr
gelobt
antonia jamin vielen herzlichen dank für
deine informationen aus tel aviv
und wären israel die einzige demokratie
im nahen osten um seine sicherheit
kämpft spielen sich hier in deutschland
wie der beschämende szenen ab 55 minuten
pure hass gegen israel mitten in berlin
wir sind das mittlerweile ja schon fast
gewohnt immer und immer wieder diesmal
sie sehen dass hier am potsdamer platz
200 menschen haben sich dort versammelt
schwenken palästinensische fahnen und
brüllen dann auch parolen wie wir haben
das gerede vom friedlich sein sat wir
werden raketen abfeuern und diese
parolen die werden dann beklatscht und
begeistert wiederholt und das verteilte
die redner auf der bühne die feiern dann
die terrorgruppen wie den islamischen
die polizei fährt hinterher sehen sie
hier mit blaulicht gleiche szenerie in
stuttgart gestern auch dort sind 80
menschen da durch die straßen gezogen
und haben den terror gegen israel
dort beklatscht und bejubelt
ihres sehen die polizei fährt hinterher
und offenbar alles geduldet nächste
reaktion werden wie der politiker sein
die sagen das dürfen wir alles nicht das
müssen wir verhindern das muss sich
alles ändern und ja wir sind es auf den
straßen es ändert sich einfach nicht
immer wieder anti israel demonstration
hier bei uns in deutschland